[Music]
Robbie good to have you here yeah thanks
for having me I'm excited to talk to you
about this epic adventure that you just
completed we've had we had a
conversation about it in Denver about
him like six weeks ago or something like
that yeah something like that yeah four
weeks month or so yeah how are you
feeling I'm feeling good yeah when I saw
you in Denver I was still in the depths
of understanding what I just done I
guess I still AM Terry gotten home yeah
yeah I think I've been home less than a
week right yeah I'd been I was in New
York for a week post run and then had
been back in Denver Yeah right week or
so yeah and it looks like you're back
running a little bit here and there I am
yeah I went as far as to try to run the
Leadville 50 a couple weeks ago I made
it halfway why
what are you that's that's definitely
what I'm asking myself now I think I
just wanted to see where my legs were
and try to understand my fitness level
and definitely found a lot out I think I
have a level of fitness I did not before
in a lot of ways the 75 day run was a
training block right but in other ways
it destroyed my legs so I have this
fitness but my legs weren't ready for
what my my body could do that makes any
sense yeah so I would imagine it's a
weird thing where part of you is like
hey man I should probably lay low for a
while but also like I just I just did
this thing like I'm crazy fit like let
me go show what I can do totally yeah
yeah I mean I'm new ish to running and
you know pretty new ultra runner I only
been running for six years I ran 250 KS
and 250 miles before I made the decision
to do this those like right on top of
each other well this I mean before I
decided to do it once I decided to do
then you've been I cackling in a year I
did a lot but you know so yeah there's
this newfound level of fitness that it's
fun to explore yet how far can I explore
yeah yeah yeah so when you decided to
run across the country you'd only done
two or three yeah 250 KS and 250 months
all right well let's paint the picture
you ran across the United States in 75
days 3,175
miles is that correct that's correct
averaging something like 45 miles a day
it was average 43 45 after ma after day
aha we had to go there to make sure
everything was gonna be in line for my
75 day finish right all right so why
like why do this yeah I mean there's
kind of a long to that I got this is for
right I believe it all really started in
2016 right at the outcome of the
presidential election I kind of was in a
place where I felt really lost didn't
understand it really
and through that I also found that I had
a lot of family members that saw things
much differently than I did and one of
those someone whom I love and who has
supported me through so much my life but
we just see the world through a
different lens my aunt we got on the
phone a couple days afterwards and I was
just spitting venom I was pretty upset
and in that conversation she posed a
question to me and she said what are you
doing so great that my opinion matters
so much and that really resonated with
me at the time I was running some
restaurants in Austin Texas and from
that point on I was also very overworked
and overstressed at my job a lot of
which I was putting on myself I think
due to a lack of confidence I wasn't
delegating I was just taking it all in
taking it all in and through that her
posing that question it put me in sub
type of existential crisis and that was
what November 2016 by September of 2017
I had left the restaurants
yeah and Wow so that's that's a you know
first of all it demonstrates your
ability to listen and hear because you
could have deflected that so something
that she said resonated with you like
she held a mirror up to you like for
sure such hot [ __ ] man
exactly and you were able to hear that
to process it and then and then the
second piece of that being that you
actually did something about it yeah I
think in that question it made me really
start to look at myself in our our
culture is a larger thing and see that
we're all so many or
chair advocates armchair pundits and
that just didn't sit well with me as an
individual so that started yeah this
longer process of figuring out what what
did I stand for and what was something I
wanted to make an impact in and what was
the process of trying to unpack that for
yourself well over the next again eight
months or so it was ten months was
figuring out that I needed to leave my
current my current career and on the
heels of that my fiance decided she want
to go to nursing school so we were gonna
move to Denver and as we made that
choice I was going to take some time for
myself and go travel Southeast Asia or
South America and at that time there the
hurricanes hit down in the Caribbean and
I lived on st. John and the US Virgin
Islands in my early 20s and I still had
a lot of friends and loved ones down
there and didn't hear from him from
awhile and you know it scared me and I
decided instead of taking that that
aloof trip abroad I would go down there
and help and when I got down there one I
ended up feeling very powerless in
helping just being an individual I think
I was there for them emotionally and let
them have someone that wasn't a part of
it there was a lot of trauma but I also
saw a couple of things one I saw wow
like mother nature's pissed this storms
filled they just felt like they were
entirely too big and too I saw hope and
happiness and people who had lost
everything everything all the things
that we all work for and somewhere in
that when I came back I knew I wanted to
do something environmentalism and so
then it was the thought of going into
solar or possibly the little wildland
firefighting but I was I had been
running prior to that a lot I'd already
done some ultras and I moved to Denver
and I just kept running more and more
and it was just where I was processing
and sifting through what I wanted to do
and in that I winded up going down to
the caballo Blanco 50 down in the Copper
Canyon at Mexico made famous by Born to
Run right and down there I met a guy
Sweeney who had ran across the country
and it just I just was like okay this is
a thing you can do hears about it who
has done it and when I came back we were
at this time my fiance and I like
understanding our food choices to a
bigger degree we were both at that point
vegetarian and I had a gut check with
myself about that and I was like here's
an environmental stance that really
matters that as individuals we can we
can do all of us can have a part in and
that's to adopt a plant-based lifestyle
and also understood due to the examples
in front of me of Scott Derek and you
like it's really good for you
performance wise so all these things
started to just circle around on my
first run back after going to the Copper
Canyon and I just hit all these things
let's do is what's the biggest thing you
can do I can run across the country like
that guy just fine and why would I do it
is to promote a plant-based lifestyle
with the initial reason being mainly
just environmentalism and so that kind
of helped to align all of my passions
and the things I understood I understand
food I've been in food my whole life and
I loved running and this environmental
crisis scares the [ __ ] out of right so
at that point though you weren't 100%
plant-based know that correct no but the
guy who Patrick is his name who ran
across the country he was he is yeah
right so he had done it plant-based he
had example was there that example was
there and another guy I found out later
has done it plant-based there's no -
dude there's no governing body over this
so it's kind of hard to say for sure
but there is like a website where they
kind of keep track of there's one who
does it though there's a Facebook group
that seems to be have a lot on there and
oh yeah there is a website that's kind
of got most of it right because every
year like a couple people made this
attempt right how many people total have
done it I think I'm proximately the 330
yeah first person was in 1909 oh yeah
yeah yeah the history of it is crazy
like there was a period of time that
doesn't get talked about or written
about very much where there was like
this people were running crazy distances
in the early 1900's 28th in 1928 1929
there were two races coined the great
bunion derbies and they were to show off
the beginning of route 66
and yeah they were stage races but they
went all the way across the country and
they were like tourism like they were
like marketed they were supposed to be
like to create awareness around this
this new highway exactly yeah yeah yeah
and which was nice they're interesting
that I ended up spending the first half
of the run on route 66 and here we are
on the other side route 66 it was just
starting and now there's not much left
of it yeah you know there's parts of it
where there's no funding and bridges are
washed out and we saw all kinds of
interesting stuff isn't that like part
of the narrative and that animated movie
cars I think it takes you know you know
that Pixar movie like it takes place on
route 66 and it's about kind of what
happens to that economy and culture when
they build the superhighway okay yes I
mean it makes all the sense that movie I
really remember it but that makes all
the sense in the world yeah right I saw
that you know yeah that's incredible
that that it dates back that far mm-hmm
so you've kind of had this journey man
life for most of your adulthood right
kind of like this into the wild you know
sort of sensibility about you yeah where
does it where does that emanate from I
don't know growing up you know my mom
really she liked to travel we never
traveled domestically but we were always
hopping around you're from Georgia I
grew up in Georgia my mom's family was
in Texas most of my childhood so I spent
a lot of time going back and forth
my mom's father he traveled a lot and
he'd take me on road trips and stuff so
I think it started there and then when I
was you know as funny set into the wild
when I was 22 I moved to Denali National
Park and they were actually filming that
movie that summer so yeah that was kind
of definitely part you know that helps
to kind of sum it up and then from there
I moved to the Virgin Islands for a
couple of years which I mentioned
earlier and then made my way to Austin
and spent the majority of the last 10
years there but during that period of
time of travel like did you have a sense
of what were you were just having an
adventure or like that was where was the
idea like I'm just gonna do this as long
as I can or do you have a sense of you
know like well I'm gonna settle down and
do X when I'm done with this oh no no no
even I think when I moved to Austin it
was a jumping point my mom had moved
there and the rest of my family
my mom's family had moved kind of to the
Austin area but I got there and anyone
that spent time in Austin knows like its
it's beautiful it's fun being in my
early 20s it was a great place to kind
of settle for a while and God had really
involved at the restaurant industry
there and had a great time yeah so you
were like part owner and a pizzeria yeah
I started off just overseeing operations
there were six employees and we had one
little spot it's beautiful restaurant
boo Felina and then from there we grew
into a second one and when we open the
second I became partner I had some
ownership in it but was overseeing
operations for the two restaurants and
yeah that was kind of what I was doing
and I was using running as a stress
reliever from all of the mounting stress
of the job Ryan so how does that how
does running enter the picture
specifically my fiancee now girlfriend
at the time she was also working at the
restaurant we started dating a couple
months after it opened and I was living
a lifestyle that's very very much a part
of I think all restaurant industries not
just the one in Austin but it was work
hard and party just a little bit harder
yeah and of course yeah and that's why
you do it
yeah it's readily available everything
booze everywhere yeah exactly and so I
was doing that but I care I really had
worked hard and ducked to making sure
that this restaurant opened it meant a
lot to me they felt like it was a big
step up for me a big like career move
and as it opened we were wildly busy
right off the bat it's it's still this
day such a beautiful successful
restaurant and the mounting stress of
that wasn't working with the partying so
much and my fiancee now she she had ran
one marathon her father was a marathoner
and she asked me to go out on a run and
we went two and a half miles and I kept
home
we got a juice at daily juice downtown
Austin and cab home that was all I had
in me but it's stuck that was it that
was the way it hit so many of the things
that that party lifestyle hit I like
I've talked about in the past it's it's
like running is the
in verse of a drug sometimes especially
when you're starting off or just getting
back in shape you feel like [ __ ] while
you're doing it and then you feel great
afterwards uh-huh order drugs yeah right
while you're doing it and then you feel
awful afterwards yeah so I really like
that I like that for me running taps
into this primal thing and it just feels
like everything aligns it's like where
I'm supposed to be what I'm supposed to
be doing it just feels so good so that
it's again it just stuck and it was two
and a half miles half marathon couple
months later Philly Marathon the next
year 50-mile or the next year
so just it was basically a light switch
got flexed and that was that yeah and
there was a another instance that really
got me in it I ran a marathon I had
heard about ultras I was clued in enough
that I think I was following some guys
on Instagram and we took a weekend long
weekend vacation up to the San Juans in
Colorado to Silverton and it just so
happened to be the weekend before Hard
Rock and went downtown silverton and
there was all the big boys they were all
there and I grew up an only child only
child but also with just a single mother
my father passed away when I was really
young and I think I've always been
wandering and searching for what does it
mean to be a man what like Who am I and
all of this and for me for so long
partying was that there there was a
sense that that was a way to be like
hardcore to be to be yeah you know a man
and being up there and seeing these guys
it was just so quick he's like well
that's another example right there and
so that really resonated with me and on
the way home I had Shelley look up how
do you qualify for hard rock I was so
naive to it that I thought I could just
you know quickly working I went to Hard
Rock don't like the hardest risk
basically in America exactly and so we
found a 50-miler that was a qualifier or
you did the 50 and in the felony I could
do the hundred and that would qualify
and so it and did winning back where I
grew up in Georgia what was it about the
ocean was it just seeing those guys and
and the access that you had because it's
such a low-key like subculture
what was it about the ultra community
that made you think this is for me as
opposed to oh I ran a marathon and I saw
these guys that won the marathon like he
could have keyed into that instead I've
always had a draw to trails and just
being more in the wilderness I grew up
on in the foothills of the Appalachians
and was always on or near the
Appalachian Trail so there's always been
a love of that living in Alaska I mean
marathons are fun I still enjoy a
marathon what's what's terrible about a
marathon is you never take a break you
know in 50 miles you come to an aid
station at least you stop for a minute
Samara you can't take a break in the
earth on yeah but no but then where is
you know ultras it's just yeah it's it
takes so much it's and you get to be
among in the middle of you can choose
these races that puts you somewhere
where you may never go a lot of that
just the grid of it you know grit would
be the word yeah well that's a pretty
quick trajectory from newbie runner into
doing ultras yeah yeah it was it was
only a couple of years I when I decided
to do that 50-mile or I had only ran the
Philly marathon uh-huh and then in the
training block to get ready for it I ran
the Boston Marathon and Hell's Hills 50k
in Smithville Texas and during that
period of time what were you relying on
in terms of how to structure your
training well actually who ended up
being my crew chief for my run across
the country
my fiancé's sister Jackie she wrote a
very basic plan for my huh and I stuck
to it you know there was just when to
run and how far to run that was it that
was it that's all you needed
yeah and I stuck to it I mean uh almost
every I think almost every workout it
right so I gather that with each one of
these races that you you did you became
more emotionally engaged with this
community in this world and you have
this thirst go farther and do more
totally absolutely yeah and then moving
to Denver kind of up to that a little
bit more you know I wasn't I didn't
personally know
any of these elite runners that live in
that area but just being amongst them
being close to them just made me just
Fein for it even more well when we had
dinner in Denver you were like I mean
you had just returned from your run so
you would move to Denver but then you
really actually didn't really live there
very much right and you were saying like
I still don't you don't like know
anybody there no yeah very little
community there because when we got
there yeah I got obsessed with this idea
I had a plan to build and I had a
sponsor to find and yeah head right get
all those things in line so you've done
these couple ultras you come back from
the Copper Canyon and you're like I'm
gonna do this so walk me through you
know the process of going from audacious
idea into actual reality you know what
this right like what happens when you
tell Shelly like when you're like okay
I'm gonna do this thing like how was
that received and you know I'm sure some
people were like slow down cowboy
yeah Shelly's always very supportive and
it was just to kind of in a
matter-of-fact okay alright let's let's
do it you know she there was some
questioning later on as I struggled to
get momentum in the way I needed to make
it happen but most for the most part
everyone around me was very supportive
and in hindsight I do think that's rare
that I didn't have along the way very
few nights hairs I had a lot of friends
that kind of chuckled that's just you
know it give me kind of a look of okay
you know but some of them ended up being
my crew as I did it so there was a big
you know like but yeah now being on the
other side of it and appreciating the
magnitude of the whole thing do you
think that you benefited from the
naivete of like not really fully
grasping what it was that you were
trying to tackle like there's something
about that innocence like when you don't
like if you had like let's say you'd
been around ultras for five or ten years
you know it's like you then you have a
sense of like how hard this is gonna be
and maybe like yeah I don't know if I
want to do that but like the enthusiasm
of being new and not really having all
the experience that perhaps one might
have suggested you need for something
like this can work to your benefit right
just like oh yeah I'm gonna do it yeah
don't worry about it well most of us in
our head anyways so just like not having
those blockers of what the status quo
would be for something like this yeah I
think it goes to my advantage right and
then it was just a matter of how am I
gonna do it you know there was the
training that had to happen and there
was creating a plan so that I could shop
that to sponsors or someone to help me
along the way and so with those two
things you know the plan or the training
plan was pretty rudimentary I kind of
broke it up into three parts the first
part I was I wanted to make sure that I
could run consistently every day so I
ran ten miles a day taking every 15th
day off and did that for a couple months
three months or so maybe longer and then
the second part was continuing to run
every day but upped it to a hundred
hundred and ten miles a week and then by
the third time the third set I are the
third block I had obtained my sponsor
not a move
day for ice cream and together we went
to a handful of races and I wanted to
make sure that I could I wanted to
normalize 50 miles so the idea was get
to race pace do it every other week
mm-hmm and do that for a while and then
if you can do it at race pace we can
hopefully I can just do it a little bit
slower but four-day yeah
days on the in so literally running an
ultra every other weekend yeah I did
backed it like two a weekend in between
two of those like two sets of those
another 100k in there and maybe a 50k -
uh-huh
so how much time between returning from
the Copper Canyon and day one of the
cross country inner in one day okay so a
year a year to get ready but not like
you'd banked you know years of ultra
races with you know everything that that
kind of happens when your body
acclimates to that kind of pounding over
time like the ligaments and the tenant
like these things take more time than
your heart and your lungs to get in
shape right so that's a lot it was it
was no real room to get injured or for
you know any margin of error no at one
point early on I
a like a neuroma on the bottom of my
foot too inflamed nerve feels like
you're just stepping on a nail and yeah
it was it was mortifying I was so scared
you know but you always can adjust
there's always I feel like a way to
adjust I'm blessed with really good
biomechanics unless I push I found when
I get injured is when I try to run fast
and luckily for this that wasn't really
part of our game alright but where did
you come up with this training plan was
that just your idea or did you start
getting some insight from some people
that know yours I love that yeah I'd
really feel I mean I again am blessed
with good biomechanics so I felt like it
was all in my head and it was a matter
of just gaining the confidence I needed
normalizing distances and I thought with
those things together my willpower
my mom always she always I remember
growing up if there was one mantra it
was you can do anything you set your
mind to and I haven't tried that one
yeah and that in this that would this
was like the ultimate test to that am i
oh no in a lot of ways this idea of
going plant-based though I mean that was
you're coming back again I keep going
back to the Copper Canyon but this is
like the genesis of all of us right the
idea of doing this plant-based are
becoming plant-based 100% I mean that
was theoretical at that point so that
you're on top of doing all this training
you're making this dietary shift at the
same time right so how did that go what
did that look like it wasn't overnight
yeah it wasn't you know we were already
vegetarian and at that point there was
no so one little tidbit
when I went down at the Copper Canyon
fat race I didn't finish it uh-huh the
first year so when I made the plan to do
this and the reason was is we were
staying at a really small hotel it felt
more like just a host family and they
offered up three meals a day and they
were not vegetarian and I didn't I
didn't want to be a difficult guest so I
was just eating what they put in front
of me and I got food poisoning the night
more the race and ended up scratching at
Mile 20 and it was some rancid chicken
mmm that was the last time I've ever had
meat
mmm that's for sure and then getting
back it was it was over a couple of
months
to where I can put before I was like
okay I am a hundred and ten percent
plant-based and I think that was
important the process in order for me as
I set out across the country to be able
to talk to others about this and I think
something that really resonates with me
is the idea of not preaching like
absolutism and allowing people to have
space to make these decisions over time
I think it's so really daunting when we
as advocates or just like you need to be
vegan right right now and instead it's I
like the idea if we have three meals a
day how many can you make a positive
change in and then over time you can
cumulatively make more and more until
hopefully at the end you've ended up
with something that's more absolute or
not you're still just doing better than
maybe you were before you were turned on
to this idea well I mean I think that's
really the only way to advocate you know
I mean this is this is how everybody
makes positive changes in their life
it's not linear and it's not perfect and
if you set up a structure or an
expectation that that's how it has to go
for people you're creating a barrier and
you're just a lien Aidid the alienating
those people who would otherwise perhaps
be interested absolutely and you're
making them destined to fail yeah
there's just I mean it is a problem in
the in the vegan community because
there's a lot of you know I mean no
matter how vegan you are there's
somebody else who's more vegan and
they're gonna tell you about it and
there's nothing that that upsets me more
well there are certain things that upset
anymore but it is upsetting when you see
somebody who's made a positive leap in
the right direction or in this direction
and then somebody from the community
tells them they're doing it wrong or
they're not doing enough or why do that
you know and and just you got to put
wind in people's sails don't like you
know snuff out that light when it's just
been you know lit for the first time I
agree yeah totally yeah negativity and
putting people down is not the way to
get anyone to do anything so I couldn't
agree more with that and going across
the country we met a lot of people you
know dairy farmers cattle farmers and
everything in between and I'll say that
we didn't have a single nice hair
about what I was out there to talk about
and I think a lot of that came from that
outlook and coming to people with
positivity and not from a point of
higher than my tee it was just you know
you're not gonna tell the dairy farmer
that he's got a change you know his
business yeah or his practice I mean
when he has gone back for generations
yeah when he'd asked me what I was doing
I just get a grant I was like I'm
running across the country to create
conversations about better food choices
I'm I'm vegan mm-hmm and we would both
just kind of grin we knew what were you
know yeah but I'm sure to a degree it
resonated to some degree with him you
know I was when I was 19 or 20 I saw
supersize me it was about when that came
out and it was the beginning of this
catalyst for change and it took another
15 years for me to end up with what I
just did right and I like to think of
that when I was out there if just being
maybe it's just putting something in
someone's ear and maybe that dairy
farmer ends up having some health issues
ten years down the road and maybe he
remembers back to meeting me and that
helps him to make a change that will
better impact his life yeah who is that
Forrest Gump dude with the beard that
ring how did it go with acclimating to
the dietary shift with with training and
recovery and the like it was all
positive you know I didn't have any
issues I had a lot of affirmations that
it was the right thing to do
with everything a the closer I got to
completely plant-based the less and less
recovery
I needed between runs another one that
really got me was flim like just not
getting out on runs and feeling clear
like I could I could breathe really well
yeah there was there was no negative
side for me I did it I didn't feel as
though that there was some like detox
like transition time that was needed I
think if you start tomorrow you're gonna
feel it within two or three days yeah
well you had to get off all that pizza
cheese yeah right that was hard
when she was like of course yeah
mozzarella all day yeah
so a year to prepare and you're ramping
up this training pretty quickly I mean
that's a lot of miles to suddenly be
putting on your legs and all these races
and all of that meanwhile just trying to
corral a the resources so you're trying
to line up these sponsors and then you
know second to that the logistics of
trying to pull this thing off I mean you
know that it's a it's a tall order to
try to figure out how you're gonna get
all the way you know 3,000 miles across
the country in one piece with people
that are because you can't do it alone
you got to get people to help you and
support you and all of that it's a it's
no small undertaking and financially
it's got to be daunting as well it was
yeah so those two parts needed to come
together and I started by making sure I
had the support around me I'd figure out
the logistics later and so I started by
driving back down to Austin and sitting
down with my fiancee Shelly's parents
there you know recently retired they had
the time and are both really smart
people and we sat down together and over
four days created an initial outline of
what I wanted to do and from there I
started shopping that around to
organizations and brands and you know a
couple doors shut in my face and really
had to look at those as just an
opportunity to see that those are not
the right fit that wasn't the right
person to bring on as my team instead of
getting defeated by it and then I
approached nada Moo dairy free ice cream
out of Austin the CEO Daniel Nicholson
is a old friend acquaintance from Austin
and I had seen through social media that
his coconut milk based ice cream company
was making some plant based advocacy
stances on social media and I contacted
him through Instagram and said hey can
we have a conversation and 30 minutes
turned into an hour and a half and the
synergy was just right it felt like this
is who I want to do it with and he
really seemed to be he put the advocacy
in front it was it was more than I had
you know a lot of why brands will come
on board with that deletes he stays is
your social media mm-hmm you know
exposure they got 800 followers
so it wasn't that yeah you know I wasn't
doing much for him he's not gonna finish
their game no no but he believed in what
I wanted to do and I and that you know
that was something as I set out on the
run that also motivated me throughout is
that belief that he had in me you know
at that point by the time I started he
had put a lot of resources into this the
company had a lot of people had put a
lot of time a lot of money and I don't
take someone's confidence in me lightly
so that was a motivating factor as well
once we decided to do this together and
then with it being an ice cream company
I thought it was a good fit it was
playful I thought that was really
important when I went to these races
building up to it we took ice cream wear
this and I realized really quick how big
of a bridge this was everybody likes ice
cream yeah you gotta you're coming if
you're leading with ice cream the doors
are open totally coconut or whatever
it's made up exactly in it it provides a
good example of where we need to head
you know we're not gonna get rid of ice
cream I don't want to see you at ice
cream ice creams great its iconic its
American and it was it's just it's a
good example of a way that we can move
forward without using animal products
and so I really liked that about the
product and with that and and it
short-circuits the divisive Ness exam
around the conversation because we can
all agree that we all like ice cream
yeah right a little peace offering I
know we gave them push cart so as I went
across the country the way we created
conversations my crew did a really good
job they took care of talking to a lot
of the people along the way and being
advocates and the way that we did that
was my I had a camper that was being
pulled by a van and we had wrapped those
with my sponsors so the van was wrapped
with nada Moo and then switch for good
dot see Bosh's right which is how we
first connected yeah exactly she she
came on late in the game and helped a
lot as well and so she wrapped the
camper and this was really cool you know
I made this look like a NASCAR team
going across country but it also it
provided a focal point for people to
come talk to us and then as people would
come up and at gas stations in rural
Oklahoma and asked what we were doing my
crew could you know they could hand them
two things and they would hand them a
pint of ice cream and a push card that
said who I was what I was doing
provided five or six recipes that they
could go on though that's final
and so that was how we created this
conversation and then a lot of the time
they would wait on me to come in whoever
was who we had engaged with and I'd get
to talk to him for a moment and then be
on my way again so that was kind of how
we how many pints of ice cream did you
guys give away I don't know that's a
good question you know we were our size
was limited but we kept reopen we all we
had was a mini fridge and a mini freezer
in the camper
we're using like FedEx shipments of more
ice cream though because you get right
along the way luckily not I'm only
recently went national so we're a team
around now like it's funny cuz when we I
was I was familiar with the brant like I
knew of the brand when we ran on that
first day but I hadn't seen it around
but now I'm seeing it yeah yeah they're
growing yeah and it's a good product has
really low low sugar compared to other
brand or other ice creams and yeah it
wasn't as hard to find as I had even
anticipated luckily as I was getting
ready for this they were also ramping up
their distribution yeah you're good
ambassador yeah one thing I gather from
this is that like I'm interested in in
the audacity of like chasing an
outrageous goal right and and kind of
the mindset that's required to do that
and you know my belief and my sense is
that you would agree with this is that
you have to first of all you have to
have the confidence that you can
accomplish something like this like deep
deep down and then you have to just or
even if you're you have some
insecurities you still have to act as if
you have to proceed accordingly and with
so many moving pieces money crew like
all these things that have to come
together in order for you to pull this
off you can't wait until all that's
figured out because the clock's ticking
and you've set this date like you have
to just presume that this is happening
right and just say it's gonna get worked
out you know you're doing the footwork
the legwork like literally in your
training and whatever you're doing on
the phone to like pull these things
elements together but that that belief
like you have to be the lighthouse
because if you don't believe it and have
that confidence how can you expect the
CEO of not amou and all these crew
people who are going to sack
is there personal time to support you in
this like they have to they have to they
get that from you right so you have to
carry that vibration yeah I think it all
came down to like I I desperately wanted
this I wanted it for a lot of reasons I
wanted it
one for the outreach for the advocacy it
meant a lot to me to start being a force
for positive change and to I was lost I
had come out of 15 years more in the
restaurant industry and it didn't feel
like I wanted to do that anymore and as
much as I enjoyed that time in my life
and I was good at what I did it doesn't
give you a lot of skill sets outside of
it and I knew whatever I did next I
wanted it to be something that fed my
soul and moving my body does and pushing
the limits of what I can do physically
so I just kept doubling down that this
is what I had to do I had to get this
together and a lot of it was just faith
that it would come together and again
going back to that mantra that my mom
instilled in me you can do anything you
set your mind to and you know it's easy
to sit here and say that it just was
that easy but there was a lot of
discouragement there were a lot of times
then I have I probably wasn't too
pleasant to be around at home and you
know my fiancee was really she's an
amazing human to put up with me through
a lot of that because there were there
was a lot of times where I was scared
you know how was I going to get this
together and and then there was that
moment you know going back to the the
plan of once I did get everything on
board I still didn't have the logistics
together uh-huh and then that all came
to a head over Christmas you know I left
again March 15th and over Christmas we
were back in Austin and I was having a
pretty big freakout I didn't have a
route I didn't have crew vehical I
didn't have a crew chief I didn't even
really have my nutrition plan yet and
luckily the support of my in-laws and my
fiancee and her sister we all sat down
around a table and we started figuring
it all out and just checking those
things off and it was the first time
where I realized how much a team
mattered
again going back to my career in the
restaurants I had I was a good leader
but I wasn't a really great delegator
and I wasn't really good at trusting in
others
fiercely independent person just have
been my whole adult life if not even in
childhood and that was my first place
where I felt overwhelmed and I had I
needed help and they all came together
so selflessly and without me having to
beg for it they did they sensed it that
I needed it and we sat down and we broke
off chunks for everybody to take care of
and within a week span most things were
in order and had I continued to try to
do everything by myself yeah you know
more than 15 little bit of a control
freak I don't know if it's yeah I guess
it's control freak it's not that I don't
believe other people are capable of
things I just have a hard time asking
yeah I think is more where it comes from
and I don't know if that's just again
only child just like really independent
mm-hmm I don't know where that really
comes from but I'm glad to say that
through this process I'm much less that
way yeah well the rap part of it seems
like it shouldn't be that hard to figure
out because so many people have done you
know 300 people have done this and they
share their routes right aren't there
like there are like specific routes
where they're like this if you're gonna
do it like this is what this is the way
you do it yeah the official route is
from San Francisco I want to say it's
from San Francisco City Hall to Tavern
on the Green and in central in Central
Park yeah I when we sat down again at
this table at Christmas I really wasn't
sure what my route was gonna be I was
looking at everything
part of me at one time really wanted to
do it through the deep south being from
Georgia I felt like it's a place that I
could talk to people in a way maybe
others couldn't and we started looking
but then someone put in in Google Maps
you know LA to New York City and just
seeing it on the map I was like well
that there nobody denies that you ran
across the country if you do that it's
definitely the longest route and at that
point like that's what I want to do I
know it's longer you know you go other
spots you can go 2,600 miles where this
one was just under thirty two hundred
and
we found that there was a race in 2011
that some Frenchman put on and it went
it was called Lani la to New York and we
found some PDF that they had left online
of a route and so we took that and we
started laying that down on Strava maps
and built out my my route because my mom
the biggest thing I was worried about
was sometimes it's really hard to judge
what is the safest route where's the
shoulders where where is the most
optimal road to run on the site I mean
I'm on the side of the road every day
for 12 hours that's a lot of time for
some something to go wrong and so that
was yeah that was how we found the route
it ended up being something that was
weighing on me but once we found that it
alleviated that and then Chris Shelley's
father he took the time to put it all
into straw the maps and then also
double-check it with Google Earth and
stuff of that nature to just make sure
it looked right right yeah it's
interesting I never really thought of it
in that much detail like it's not
necessarily like the best route isn't
necessarily the most direct route
obviously you want to stay off the busy
roads where there's lots of traffic and
it's dangerous but if a busier road has
a broader shoulder than a country road
where you're gonna be running in uneven
gravel and there is no shoulder then how
you know like you might want to go with
the busier road I prefer the shoulder
yeah yeah interesting all right and how
do you begin to put the nutrition plan
together to figure out like how you're
gonna eat and like how much you're gonna
eat and what your your stomach's gonna
be able to tolerate I mean I know you
have like an iron gut and all of that
but still that's that's got to be a
tricky equation to sort out it was and
I'm not a nutritionist you know I love
food I understand food I understand food
on a higher level and restaurants and
such but what it's going to take to fuel
me exerting that much was was not my
specialty
uh-huh but luckily in my corner was
Jackie Shelly's sister and she just the
year before had done the Appalachian
Trail plant-based and so coming into it
and she also had gained some plant-based
nutrition certification in that time and
is someone who aspires to get into more
point
nutrition and she put it together and
she's a spreadsheet whiz and the idea
was high fat high carbohydrate we
figured I would need but we thought we'd
start with about 5,000 calories a day
and ramped it up to about 10 when we got
out there we ended up just like Des
Moines it was 7,000 and then 8,000
pretty much another month in and it
stayed there so I'm seven eight thousand
calories but yeah that was i left that
on her and i just had faith that she
could she could pull it together and i
mean it didn't I didn't have to have
faith she's a very capable human I knew
she would and yes she devised the meal
plan and a lot of it was made up in
smoothies
they had thousand calorie smoothies that
I had four times a day well like a lot
of coconut oil like high fat coconut
milk chia seeds bananas carrots kale
powder peanut butter in Soylent we used
some Soylent no littering there and it
just really rounded things out and made
sure we got the calories where we needed
it and what kind of real food were you
chewing on in the mornings I'd start off
with a bowl of oatmeal and with maple
syrup and chia seeds and bananas a big
bowl of that a cup of coffee and then I
stopped every five miles right so if I
the first five I'd have that first
smoothie second one a big bowl of fruit
third one smoothie and then like more
more carb starchy cold pasta we went
through a lot of things for the things I
would eat during the middle of the day
started off I come up with this kind of
vegan bond me and it was just sliced
bread with tofu hummus cilantro and like
cucumbers or something like that and
quickly I did not want bread bread was
not working for me and I think it was
more because they were pre making the
sandwiches and got soggy and I just
couldn't do the soggy bread so we ended
up doing every rendition of that
possible it was with it was in tortillas
it was just loose in a bowl and then we
moved on to cold pasta and vegan
quesadillas and mac and cheese
or vegan mac cheese a little bit and
then yeah just stuff like that starchy
car be right things and then at the end
of the day
I would have liked a camping meal
outdoor herbivore and I would have a
double portion of that cooked down with
coconut milk so the coconut milk went a
long ways and peanut butter
no gels or any other kind of well you
one of the things you said was you
didn't drink
you really didn't drink any water right
like you word it was all electrolyte
drinks yeah it was scratch i used to
scratch the whole way through some
reading we had found some people in the
past too it said they didn't drink much
water there were two things that Jackie
recommended that I was like no I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna need to do that and
one was that I wouldn't drink water and
two was that I would need that I would
need ate every five miles I thought I
could make it 15 20 miles every day
without no ha and those two things she
was completely right on but I I get the
the aid thing I think the no water thing
like I don't understand that it was
calories each each of my water bottles
that I carried on me most time I carried
a hydration vest with two water bottles
and each one had sixty calories in it
and you just when you're doing something
like this you need to get those calories
when ever you can wherever you can and
it was replacing the salts so I just
stuck with it we just found that
whenever the end of the day when we
would tally up how many calories I was
getting we kept a pretty good log of
that had I not been drinking scratch all
the time we would have been in a deficit
where with it it was just allowing
everything to flow I mean day one we
started that and we just kept going with
it so when you're depleting yourself of
salts at that kind of a rapid rate it's
like too easy to get hyponatremia is
that the idea yeah and I sweat a lot so
it was a fear and I you know in races
have always been one that I take salt
ABS about every hour I didn't out there
the scratch was taking care of it so we
just stuck to the scratch it did the job
and it was one of the things if it's not
broke don't fix it right and it held up
the whole time so this whole thing comes
together you get the funding you get the
sponsors you get the crew you get the
van wrapped you got dot see you know
everybody is on board and I joined you
for that first day in Huntington it was
Huntington right yeah
we ran from the pier and it was cool
like there was a whole scene of people
like there was a it was there was a lot
of you know structure and formality to
this whole thing like I was like wow
this guy's got [ __ ] together this is
really happening
and was really fun because we hadn't met
to get to know you a little bit that
morning and then at some point I was
like all right dude I'm out like I gotta
turn around and go home and you just I
just watched you like run off into the
distance and I just thought man that guy
like what an adventure lies ahead for
you like I you know that there was it
was so exciting that warning but how
long before that wears off and the you
know the reality starts to dawn on you
morning waking up day - yeah I mean that
the most daunting part of the whole
experience was the mornings right when I
wake up it was just like are you kidding
me
again you know again 1215 hours today so
it was quick that you know I coming into
this I'd spoke to a couple of people who
had done this or something similar and
there were two to things that they told
me and ones if you could make it through
the first two weeks without a
show-stopping injury your body would
hold up and the second was after the
first month it would get a little bit
easier hmm and those two things really
rang true day three was extremely hard
day three I hallucinate it his first
time from running have I ever
hallucinate it and it was a wild ride
what is Sun it was early on in the day
every there was a this in in retrospect
it feels as though there were two days
that felt like this where everything
almost had like an Instagram filter on
it like kind of dark like the Tokyo
filter on your huh and it was just dark
and spooky kind of and that was kind of
the visual of it and I had a unfounded
fear of a dog coming out of nowhere and
biting me and also I my senses were in
overload when cars would come by I would
I would just cower and and at one point
I had to go into a diner D to use the
restroom and at that point coming out I
was mortified that I was going to come
in contact
to someone that scared me or that was
sketchy or for whatever whatever it was
and I just battled with that for the
majority of that day and like weird
paranoia weird paranoia weird and I
think a lot of that was a hormonal thing
I think everything was realigning a lot
of this is about adaptation it's about
applying a pressure over time and
eventually your body and your mind
adapts and this was my mind
where the part where my mind started to
say no no we don't we don't do this and
I had to continue to just say yes we do
yes we do and so that that kind of
started it off with that that was one of
the weirder days
yeah this weird war that you're waging
with your body and your mind you would
think that it would be a more linear
thing where you start off fresh and you
just kind of progressively get more and
more tired and hopefully you make it to
the other side but I've never done
anything near like what you've done but
in my limited experience it is a strange
thing where it's like you start off
great then it gets hard and then
suddenly it's really hard and and you're
like I'm done this is and then there's
if you can stick with it there's a weird
breakthrough where it's almost as if
your body and I wrote about this might
look like your body goes okay like now I
get it like I I misunderstood you know I
thought you're trying to kill me now
that I know that that you're not like
now we can get on the same page you know
and then suddenly there's almost like
this rejuvenation period that happens
where you then enter kind of like a flow
with the whole thing yeah I couldn't
agree more
and isn't the same true with other
choices in life wanting to quit
something or start something oh it kind
of goes like that and I think that's
something for important for people to
understand is just because something's
hard in the beginning doesn't mean it's
always going to be there's always an
order to it and and if you break through
it doesn't mean that then it's gonna be
easy after that either no no no but I
think there is a tipping point where you
know it it does get a little bit easier
and then it's maintenance
I didn't once it got easier I didn't
mean I didn't have to run every day
right but it did become a little more
just who I was and what I did mm-hmm so
yeah it was mind and embody the body had
two main
main moments where it almost broke and
it was early day seven I think I got
shin splints and my I believe is my
right shin and anyone said shin splints
I mean that's that's awful
and it's one of the things where in
normal day what would you do if you got
shin splints you would rest elevate ice
rest I didn't have a lot of time to
elevate or ice definitely have any time
to rest so it was a lot of luckily with
my crew we just started troubleshooting
and we figured out some things we
changed shoes I was wearing mm-hmm that
was a big thing they were wearing
initially you're wearing like a zero
drops I was yeah zero drop shoe which
had really worked for me in the past it
was something that I've been running
with in in the last years a couple years
before just for this application it was
not right and really found out quick
that the right answer was the Ho Chi
Bondi sixes they're the most cushioned
shoe they have they've got a good drop
in on them so you're always just kind of
helping to push your leg your feet along
and that was a huge step in the right
direction and then the other one was
interesting I didn't have to stick to it
the whole time but in order to overcome
this I needed to put on ankle socks
there was something about the mobility
of my ankle that allowed once I allowed
it to be free to move as it wanted to
that I could tell that instantaneously
and then we put a compression sleeve on
the leg as well so prior to that you
were wearing a sock that covered your
ankle yeah it's like a crew sock you
know and not a ton of compression there
but it was just enough I mean it's just
you know as you get longer distances it
ultras and like all the things you've
done it the little things add up over
time it's just these little tweaks and
these little things it's like a little
pebble in your shoe can destroy it
yeah that's that's the crazy thing right
and no matter how much you try to
control for every single variable and
there's innumerable variables and what
you're trying to do it's it's this weird
like thing you'd ever thought of that's
so tiny yeah it makes or breaks you yeah
absolutely and that was one of them it
was it was overcoming those things and
putting those three things changing
those three things compression saw or
compression sleeve given the mobility
than equal different shoe back back on
track that's crazy because
shin splints don't go away overnight mmm
so he went over they went away over five
nights
uh-huh and you know so you just you just
ran through it and it just slowly
dissipated yeah through that we were
every five miles for a couple of days at
least every other five I was taking more
time on my stops I was elevating and
icing in order to overcome it
I found throughout the thing if I ever
got where there was an it's pain
starting in my feet or in my legs
elevating went a long way it's just
getting all the blood back to where it
should be yes or that that was how he
overcame that one and then day 19 it was
tendinitis and the other ankle right
that one came compiled with a mineral
break as well emotionally mentally
physically on day 19 the Wills fell off
everything just came came crashing down
I had the night before realized that I
was having this pain in my ankle I woke
up the next day and again this was the
second day where I got that that weird
Instagram filter and everything got
really dark I called my fiance and I I
just lost it emotionally I know the best
way I've been able to describe it is I
was crying so hard like snot was coming
out of my nose just just done just so
broke broken and when I came into my 15
mile stop I was dragging my leg
literally dragging it and my crew
insisted that I take a two-hour nap um
and so I did and when I woke up there
was I didn't hide the inability to even
step on my foot I couldn't walk much
less much less run and so we decided to
take the rest of the day off he wanted
me to sleep in the following day and
when I woke up we could get in whatever
miles I could do and I woke up the next
day and again I could not I couldn't
step on my I'm not leg at all so they
talked me into just taking the whole day
off which was interesting it really took
a lot that day it was there was a lot
for me to process and a lot for me to
let go of what I realized and that was
up until that point I had been it had
been brute force
I just been forcing this with everything
in me and actually something that got me
through it was Jackie my crew chief was
not out there at the time
but she sent me a voice memo and she'd
somehow managed to record your audio
book in the part where you're floating
in the water day 2 or 3 right of your
thing and talking about succumbing to
the task at hand and how it's really not
in your control and that was one of the
things that helped me to let go of this
brute force I couldn't do that I had too
many days ahead of me and I had to go
with the flow and I had to to listen to
my body and and succumb to something
bigger and I you know I don't know
exactly what that was but I definitely
from that day on was able to just have
more again faith that I was going to get
through this and it was gonna be
something that I was going to do and it
couldn't all just be up to brute force
that's really beautiful because I I
believe in my heart of hearts that the
greatest accomplishments occur or the
breakthroughs occur when you can get to
that place where you can let go or you
can surrender and avail yourself to a
higher power of whatever that looks like
for you and I think as somebody who is
you know certainly you've got to be a
competitive person to even you know have
have the dream of trying to do something
like this there's that scent there's
there there's a willfulness with that
right and your rugged independence and
like you know being a single child and
all that kind of stuff informs this
worldview where you have to take care of
your own [ __ ] and like yeah you need
help but like fundamentally it's about
you right and and ultimately what I
think one of the amazing things about
the ultra world is it forces you to
confront the limitations of that and and
the people that really succeed and
maintain success over periods of time
are the people who can let go and and
hold on to those dreams and those goals
a little bit more loosely to ask for
help and allow help to come in and and
tap into something more fundamental that
ultimately is a more sustainable source
of power yeah I agree
and that was it was a profound day I
know without a doubt that day will stand
with me
more than most on this trip and it will
be one that stays with me for a long
time and I think now that I've finished
and I'm understanding the new me that's
come out the other end it's definitely a
big part of that is you know anxiety is
something I've battled in my life a lot
and a lot of it is then I don't know
where it's coming from a lot of times I
think it was a fear of it all falling
apart whatever that thing is and that
lesson that day made me realize that
there's a flow and there's there is
something that hopefully will keep you
going and you don't have to be so
forceful and that idea that something is
gonna fall apart
require it basically behind that is in
order for it to not fall apart like it's
on you right like you're the one who's
gonna have to make sure that everything
is firing on all cylinders so that this
thing that wants to fall apart won't
fall apart yeah and and that's how you
flame out exactly right so that's like a
huge that's it is a it's a it's a
physical breakthrough but it's more it's
more it's predominantly like a spiritual
breakthrough absolutely yeah and I knew
going into this all right there was a
hope and a desire that those kind of
things would happen I think setting out
my work yeah and you'd be naive to think
things like that are not over 75 days of
pushing yourself and and yeah that day
was profound it put a lot of things in
perspective and allowed me to move
forward in a much more sustainable way
after that again up until then I think I
was treating it as an ultra like as I
had in the past which was just brute
force just give it I mean I was
calculated I wasn't pushing at race pace
I knew when certain things started to
slow down but something did
fundamentally change that day yeah
acceptance accepting what is exactly
rather than fighting it but still how do
you go from not being able to put weight
on your leg to running that doesn't just
disappear no it didn't I did I took the
day off day 20 day 21 I got up and
everything felt pretty good and we
decided I was gonna walk that day I was
gonna walk 40 miles so up until that
day we had broken up the segments in
different distances so for the entirety
of the 75 days it was going to be
anywhere from 20 at 28 miles a day to 60
that was wreaking havoc on me
emotionally it's you know big days
having a 52 mile day I couldn't think
more than a day or two ahead mm-hmm and
I would ask midday well how much do I
have tomorrow and just seeing one of the
crew members just look at me with like
they didn't want have to tell me maybe
like it's 50 you know so anyways so that
day we got off of the track of what it
had to be and it was what it could be
and I was gonna walk 40 I made it three
miles and the pain came right back and I
was scared that I knew going into this
that if anything was gonna stop me it
was going to be an injury that was the
only thing that was gonna stop me and I
was worried that this is it this is that
injury but then right away it was ok
let's start tweaking things what can we
tweak and the first thing that came to
mind I knew we had packed some ace
bandages and I asked the pilot car that
was with me to go back to the camper
grab a nice bandage and I was gonna try
something and they did and they came
back and I wrapped my ankle quite
tightly and it was essentially the
opposite was needed as was needed for
the shin splints the lowering mobility
decrease the pain significantly and I
was I was able to start walking so I
made it 10 miles just under just under
10 miles again I'm stopping every 5 and
up on the horizon I saw some people
running towards me and my first thought
was okay this is some people who random
people from the area that went run with
me and as much as that was what I was
out there for this was not the day I was
I wasn't sure housing to cope with it as
I got closer I realized it was three
friends from Denver who had just that
was the day they had picked ball time
before and they surprised me and showed
up and it was the best thing that could
have happened to me on so many levels it
gave me company that I me it was perfect
that again that was a higher power maybe
at work and they proceeded to walk out
30 miles with me for the rest of the day
took 15 and a half hours and we walked
out 40 miles and then the following day
they left that night
and I still owe them all so much it was
such a good day that's beautiful what
could have been one of the worst days
ended up being one of the best and then
the following day I ran walk 40 miles
maybe one more day after that and then
we settled on 45 from that day out and
that would give me that would get me to
New York in my 75 days and also provide
a cushion in case something else
happened why was 75 days so important I
mean ultimately does anyone care whether
it would take you 75 or 90 or 100 or 80
the ultimate goal is to complete it Yeah
right and not in peril you know that
larger goal because you're on some
unrealistic timeframe goal it was
arbitrary but it was a goal I set and
once I did it was part of the narrative
and therefore I wanted it to I wanted to
do it that for me personally was a sign
of success had I taken longer fine and I
would have still been very happy with my
accomplishment but I think you need a
metric to hold to and I wanted to hold
to it the best I could I wasn't gonna be
devastated and quit had I not been able
to but I wanted to try everything in me
to make sure I did it in that time and
also seven five days a long time yeah
you know as much as it's oh you could
have taken longer less mileage that's
more days out there you know there's
some other folks who have completed this
year and they've taken a little bit
longer and for me it sounds worse like
yeah exactly like I enjoyed this I did
in a lot of ways but it's that type to
fun it also has the side of it that it's
somewhat miserable and you're away from
your family and your friends and your
life and 75 days meant wrap it up get it
done what's the fastest that anybody's
done Peter Cole snick he just did it in
last couple years it's incredible like
45 49 somewhere right what I did yeah I
mean every routes different yeah this is
a little lower mileage he did the the
again the official San Francisco to New
York and I'm not I want to say it's like
2,800 26-28 right he's moving I mean
some survived 80 miles a day or
something like that he's in he's
incredible
he went from Kenai Peninsula to Key West
in a hundred days solo
Wow yeah I know I've not met this guy
but I want to shake his hand because the
American wow that's unbelievable
so as you're as you're progressing
through this you're sharing these daily
updates on Instagram little videos and
you're quite transparent about like
what's going on and it was really cool
to follow that how often were people
dropping in on you like out of the blue
like to just run along to that like bill
and steam as you went along it did yeah
more and more as we hit the East Coast I
think a lot of that's just population
density yeah we're more people that were
engaged with this you're just in the
middle of nowhere Oklahoma there were
few people yeah so it did grow as we
went across and it was heartwarming and
amazing and you know there were a couple
instances people I did not know at all
who now I consider good friends there's
something about that I mean yeah you
have this time with each other when
you're running and you're running that
distance and people are spending half a
day with you running there's nothing to
distract us you get good conversations
and what did that be random people that
are now friends of mine due to this
experience or friends and family that
came out that I got to reconnect with in
a way I grew up I had a cousin who we
were like brothers growing up and then
adulthood hit and life happens and our
lives went a little bit different ways
he has kids and a family and I don't he
was in Georgia I have left a long time
ago and I've always he's been dear to me
but we've had little very little time as
adults together he came out and on the
first day he went from his longest run
was 13 miles to a marathon mm-hmm and
ran with me all day off and we were able
to know him on such a deeper level than
I did before that and I'd run across the
country just for that that experience
yes you know so those those kind of
things meant a lot it was really amazing
to have that time again with people that
I did know and then with others that our
friends you know they can keep up with
each other whether it just be on social
media or text but there's a couple of
them and where does the the advocacy
aspect of this begin to creep up like I
would imagine you're running you
through farms and people are coming out
and we talked when we had dinner you
were talking about was it the Navajo
Nation running through like what that
experience was like so I want to hear
about that but you know walk me through
how that kind of worked again it was the
focal point being the camper in the van
being wrapped as they were they're very
colorful all blues and whites and
through rural America they just don't
see stuff like this you know it's it's
different if you're here in LA or in
Austin Texas or wherever and everybody's
trying to somebody else doing something
crazy yeah exactly
that doesn't happen again in rural
Oklahoma so people were just coming out
they were stopping on the side of the
road they were at gas stations Walmart
parking lots you name it coming out
asking what we were up to and then it
just created conversations and some of
my crew were also plant-based and
advocates you know want to spread the
message and others are not but they
understood how important it was to me so
they they played the part and you know
those that are in that situation that
we're not I know in talking with them in
retrospect it definitely impacted them
as well and they they make different
choices with food now yeah so it was
just all on the way grassroots as it
could be just just meeting people as
much as we could
and some of the crew members were really
assertive in that and they would make
the point and they would go out and say
hey guess what this guy's doing you know
and others would wait for him to come to
them right no meat no dairy already
doing what yeah and you know going into
this that was something I you know I
said about supersize me and this
epiphany it gave to me I didn't
understand how bad fast food had been
was for me it was a catalyst for change
a lots changed in 15 years
and I wasn't aware of that but I'd say
that no one was just caught off guard
everyone understood what plant-based but
they knew a vegan was and I found that I
don't know under snow igloo or how to
crack this yet but rural America is
ready they want to talk about this too
and we focus so much in the plant-based
food industry and as advocates I feel
a lot of that emphasis is placed on
urban areas and people with whom we're
closely more closely identified with but
there's a whole swath of America out
there that needs to hear it wants to
hear it well what's what's mind-boggling
is the extent to which the breadbasket
of America is actually a food desert
like they don't they don't even eat the
food that they're producing it gets
shipped elsewhere it's used for you know
feed for for cattle etc and in a lot of
those places there just aren't the
healthy options that you would imagine
would proliferate yes that's where
they're growing it it's true and I think
a lot of times that's kind of thrown out
there is a reason why we don't go to
those places but desired creates demand
and then if people are asking for it
hopefully somebody shows up for that and
I think that we have to talk about it
and then as we talk about it over time
hopefully we find mechanisms to get that
food to people what was the most
surprising encounter that you had along
the way individual encounter Navajo
Nation just some really more interesting
playful conversations one guy in
particular who stopped on the side of
the road he whipped his car around his
truck and he got out he was taking
pictures of me as I came up and as I got
closer to him I he said hey my wife told
me if I saw the tall bearded white man
running through our nation I had to stop
and get a photo and that realization
that this whole community was was
embracing me one person in stock Davis
beforehand got a photo and it had made
it onto these Facebook groups that they
had in their community and little did I
know after that every car that passed me
I had the feeling that I knew what I was
doing and they were supported so that
was a really profound experience that a
general yeah if you if you handle that
in elegantly it could have gone in a
very different direction right there's
protocol like you can't just roll out
and roll onto the nation and expect to
be welcomed right did you
some light work ahead of time and let
everybody know this is what you were
gonna do or how did that go down
no there was a lot of naivety we I don't
think anyone realized how big it was
huge it's the size of West Virginia it
took eight days to run through em hmm
and it tested me the first full day in
the nation
I had blisters on top of blisters on top
of blisters it was awful
I felt as though I was running it with
just raw heat and I was concerned about
being there and being on in a nascent
other nation it's someone else's it's
not mine and it's just a overwhelming
sense of-of welcome 'no snow and i don't
i do know that my crew all along the way
and especially those that were with me
at that time are open hearted kind kind
people and I had no anxieties that we
were gonna instigate anything negative
but I think a lot of it comes from the
pride those people they hold in
stewardship of their land and the pride
they they felt pride that I chose to go
through there mm-hmm and I think a lot
of that came from maybe that a lot of
people try to skate around it for those
same anxieties and fears that I was
feeling and instead we just pushed
forward and they were extremely
welcoming and comforting and responsive
to that's beautiful
yeah it was it was really an amazing
space today it was my favorite part of
the tree and what was their receptivity
to the whole vegan thing but more like
per capita probably the most like no no
naysayers anywhere throughout the whole
experience but in there I felt as though
they were listening on a deep level and
a lot of the people we were coming in
meeting were what they would even
consider like the elders like there were
some generations below them and they had
a lot to say about how they had seen
their communities get fatter and become
less healthy and Wendell the guy I was
talking about earlier he he went as far
as to say you know when I was a kid I
remember
my dad and his his friends being built
more like you and they ran you know I
mean indigenous cultures are known for
running yeah you know it's not just the
Tata my Navajo have their own history
there and they they were again receptive
and I just hope that I can't see what
the repercussions were for my actions I
only know what I saw and hoped that that
catalyst was there and maybe there was
some change that happen yeah but I
talked about food deserts oh that's
that's to a level even further is there
grocery shopping at gas stations is not
fair
yeah and obesity diabetes like the rates
are crazy yeah you know in these
reservations wow what an amazing
experience yeah that was a really great
area just unexpected and beautiful yeah
what was the hardest part to rain wise
late in the game the Appalachian
emulation oh they were relentless I mean
cuz they're up down up down up down they
don't understand what switchbacks are
everything's straight up straight down
and I grew up in that blasians there was
something interesting about that I you
know as an adult I've always gravitated
further west and really enjoy the
Western scape and having gone back east
into the Appalachians much other than
that first initial 50-miler I did I felt
a sense of being at home there which was
really interesting that I definitely
won't definitely want to explore more
but coming into it my splits were
getting faster again I was doing 45
miles a day from day 22 on so we had
this good metric we had this way to see
how I was doing and I was cruising every
day it was just a little bit shorter a
little bit shorter and then we hit
somewhere in West Virginia and it was
literally hit a wall and that wall
continued to be up for three miles and
down for three miles for six days six
seven days and it tested me I got to
where those 45 miles were taking me 11
hours I was back to 16 hours it's a lot
of extra time on your feet yeah and what
it also does is when you're on your feet
that long it allows less time to come
down at the end of the day instead of
getting to feel human for a minute and
sit with my crew and talk and laugh it
was straight to bed right get up and do
it again and everything just starts
becoming so much more
just this linear mess of running uh-huh
so the Appalachians they tore me up it
was also humid it was getting warm and
yeah yeah that is what what what was the
recovery protocol when you would finish
each day it was definitely the weakest
spot in my plan I hadn't planned really
well for recovery I had this sense that
if I ran so much every day I'd just be
tired and I'd pass out and it didn't
work that way I dealt with the mints
throbbing pain and my glutes and quads
down even felt like the bones in the
first couple weeks I didn't get a lot of
sleep I think the first week I'd say I
got Kia mode of ten hours of sleep Wow
and 10 hours cumulative for the first
week because you would think yeah you're
exhausted you'll just sleep through the
night yeah yeah no the pain was too much
I couldn't like I was I would wake up
with my feet where my head should be in
my head with my feet should be and then
I'd wait get up and I'd walk around the
camper
I'd do whatever I could to just try to
alleviate this pain we built we've got
some of those like swimming pool noodles
from a Walmart and we bound them
together so I could have a something to
put my legs up so I would elevate my
legs while I slept in the bed and it
just it didn't work nothing was really
working and then it ended up being a
like a concoction of some cayenne pepper
supplements pills like two Tylenol CBD
to get me to sleep and it was company
called pure power they reached out and
sent out this like supplement thing they
have and one of them was powered down
and that power down was a sleeping aid
like an herbal sleeping aid and
melatonin and really I don't know that
it was at the pain went away or I just
slept through it they did overtime and
you know is that as crazy to think that
you would need all this assistance going
to sleep yeah yeah tarragon
you know I slept I slept with a gun by
my bed
very good yeah Derek but no like Norma
tech boots and ice baths and masseuses
nothing like you didn't even like a head
like oh hey we're coming into an urban
era area can we see if we can get
somebody to come out here and do some
deep tissue massage or anything like
that no no none of that you know I put
on my first pair of Norma tech boots
afterwards was that when you were at
recover recover in New York yeah they
hooked me up with all yeah absolutely
but no I did not the only time we almost
seeked help I can't remember what day it
was
it was midway through and all of a
sudden I realized I was dragging
big-time I I couldn't figure it out
every day I'd wake up and I had less
energy than I did the day before I
couldn't get going and we were concerned
that something was off as far as
nutrients you know was it low and iron
this and that and we were at that time
scheduling for me to go get some blood
work to try to figure out what it was
and I'd one morning just realized I was
like I feel like I just haven't had
coffee and we've been using instant
coffee just for convenience for the crew
now I came into the next aid stopped I
said hey I see the bottle of instant
coffee were using and they had picked it
up at a convenience store and it was
expired so there's no caffeine oh yeah
so this this deficiency I was having was
caffeine you got a caffeine deficiency
yeah yeah and that was that was that was
though when you hit you hit that first
cup of real coffee first cup of joe we
were like to go back did you do any drip
blood pools along the way is so that you
could you know register the iron levels
and all that kind of stuff
no I one of my biggest regrets from the
whole experience was going into I got
blood work done before I left home
everything was was spot-on
vitamin D was a tiny bit off but it was
middle of the winter in Denver which
Denver usually sunny it was off a little
bit everything else was spot on I
haven't had a blood work since I really
wish I right away you were at recover
they did they pull blood there they
could
I don't I don't know I didn't see any
what are you not done but I should have
it's definitely regret yeah but you feel
good now I feel great yeah you know even
coming out of it
even as I finished again we talked about
earlier like if she would just
progressively get more tired along the
way I I had this assumption that I would
just crawl through the finish in New
York I finished strong yeah I went for a
run three days later yeah I you know I
went out around New York with John
Joseph and some folks on what
international running day uh-huh and if
what the human body is capable of like I
went and joined the iron cowboy on the
last day of his oh yeah 50 consecutive
higher Mane's and ran the final marathon
with him and he was throwing down a
serious pace like the last 10k like he
was running sub seven-minute miles I was
playing around with that along the way I
had one consistent crew member who was
with me the whole time
Elliott there's a whole story there I
met him two weeks before we started the
run and I would just play with him like
in the last couple weeks and I dropped
down to sub seven mile just just to see
him react and I could do it though yeah
that was what was interesting is I I was
getting stronger as I went yeah and I do
give a lot of that to the plant-based
diet you're putting about you know stuff
in your body that's building it up
instead of tearing it down and with that
diet - I don't understand how somebody
could consume eight thousand calories a
day if it wasn't plant-based I just I
just don't you know but I do think that
that had a lot to do with my ability to
feel strong throughout no cheeseburgers
no she's very yeah talk to me about how
you like the process what it feels like
and the process of walking through like
confronting obstacles like when you're
out there and you're just like I can't
even go mm-hmm one more step like how do
you break that down and work your way
through it because I think like whether
for a lot of people like they're gonna
they're gonna hear this and they're like
I can't even relate to this right but if
we if we drill down to the s
of what it is which is like confronting
yourself in the most fundamental way and
strategies for quelling the resistance I
found early on that every single day was
different that helped a lot there were
whole days that sucked really bad but I
quickly understood that one bad day had
no correlation to the next whatsoever
I could be on top of the world and the
next day crashed down but vice versa so
in those hard days it was a matter of on
the bigger scale just get through today
and tomorrow is gonna be different
there's a good chance of a better and
then I broke this up I ran across the
country in 5-mile segments every every
we stopped five miles for me to eat and
Andrey and get rehydrate and a lot of it
was just just not looking too far ahead
like having amnesia for what had
happened and just blindly going into the
next thing just keeping it
compartmentalizing compartmentalizing
having small small goals that
cumulatively over time would equal a
greater goal uh-huh
yeah it's it was an interval workout
yeah 600 times 5 miles right exactly
yeah so that you know that did a lot for
me was in that it's amazing what we're
capable of and I think a lot of what you
have to do is not get overwhelmed by the
larger task at hand whatever it is and
just start chopping away little by
little at whatever you're trying to
achieve nobody gets to something huge
overnight it's gonna take time so the
the original kind of activist aspect of
this began from mostly an environmental
perspective right but my sense is that
that's kind of evolved yes that
definitely has environmental is still a
very big part of it for me no doubt I've
talked to others about this and how
becoming plant-based when you make that
switch there's a level of compassion and
see that just happens and I don't I
don't understand it completely but it
definitely happened for me and the way I
sleep easier at night and I have this
this this overwhelming sense of that
it's the right move just based on the
fact that I I'm not creating suffering
for any other beings mm-hm
and that aspect of it has definitely
come to the forefront for me and as I
was running across the country there
were a lot of livestock that I came in
contact with I saw way more cows than
people and understood it much I grew up
my grandfather had cattle I was young
you know you're not really good thinking
too deep about much but one thing that I
definitely I think I gained along the
way was just how aware these these
animals were and how much they were they
were curious beings they cars go by all
day they know what a car is they don't
know what a guy running is yeah I want
to come see what it is and they're
playful they all come to the fence when
you're come to the fence and run with
you
whines there was a day where it was it
was one of the few days that snowed I
woke up and there was snow all over the
ground and I started my my daily miles
and there had been a calf who it had
been separated from its mother had
somehow gotten out of the fence so it
was on the roadside with me very
desolate road in the middle of Oklahoma
I believe and I had for the better part
of an hour had to hear this calf cry for
its mother and its mother gets separated
from the pack and keep looking between
do I go with the pack how do I want to
stay with my child and it was
gut-wrenching
it was no different than seeing that in
a human and eventually luckily the calf
found a spot to get back through and it
made its way to its mother and they
trotted off but that that part matters
that part of the advocacy matters more
to me now than ever and those two right
there and I mean just overall health and
well-being you know we live in a society
with a lot of problems and a lot of good
things but
you look at a lot of the problems in
front of us and I and that was when I
got into this I felt there was this like
this naive epiphany that a plant-based
lifestyle was like a silver bullet it
could take care of so many of the
problems in front of us it could take we
we we have all these talks and all of
this debate about health care and how to
how to approach health care in America
what if people just weren't sick you
know the environmental crisis is huge
it's looming and animals production
animal production equates for you know
it said over 50 percent of the
degradation of our environment silver
bullet right it's deep plants and so
that that it it means it does mean a lot
to me and it has evolved a lot over time
and it's just there's three pillars to
it to me there's environmentalism
ethical and health mmm-hmm and those
three still stand true it's like what
matters and why it is such an important
topic one important enough to run yeah
country for yeah it checks all of those
boxes if we avoid animal products in our
diet we can avoid chronic lifestyle
illnesses we can sidestep the
environmental wreckage that this
industry provokes and produces and we
get to spare the lives of these sentient
beings and we need not raise so many of
them only to lead them to you know a
most unpleasant demise exactly so it
seems like really Elementary to me but I
think the role of the athlete what's so
important about the athlete is people
might intellectually be able to kind of
understand that but then they still
think yeah but I'm gonna be deficient or
I'm not gonna feel good or I'm not going
to be able to do what I want to do in my
life so you can go and get in front of a
microphone and say the things that you
just said but ultimately the power in
your message is the fact that you got
across the country in 75 days
opportunity which is undeniable and
can't be debated yeah right in that
there so that was one of the reasons I
got into this too was as we were making
all these changes in our life and we
were talking about
plant base and we had gone vegetarian I
was expressing this to friends and
family and they knew that I like to run
a lot and there was that thing of you
can't do this Robi like you you really
you're gonna need you need that meat for
strength so you can run and it was just
one of those things if like well what's
a way to prove that you know and that
was definitely circling around in this
time huh yeah and going into this I
wasn't really aware of plant-based
advocacy you know I didn't understand
that there were so many others out there
that were working towards this and some
you know that was an interesting thing
to realize that there was a whole
fraternity of others that were involved
which has really been awesome to
understand and see and I do
I think athletes we do poison we stand
poised in a very interesting position
because it's if it's good for us why is
it good not good for everyone else yeah
you know yeah again if we can perform at
this well then everybody in their normal
lives and weekend warriors dates good
for them too right
the human mind though is pretty good at
at denial and dissonance so it's you
know they'll look at what happens
unfortunately is the more extreme and
audacious the athletic feat like in the
case of yourself running across the
country it then becomes unrelatable and
then you just become an outlier who's
easily dismissed as like a freak like
yeah he could do it but like he's a he's
like you know he's not like me yeah so
then the challenge becomes you have to
bring it back and make it relatable
again and that's why I think it's
important for you to talk about the fact
that you haven't been a runner your
whole like that's what I wanted to hear
like that part of the story too because
I think people can see themselves in
that that you're not some crazy
superhuman Superman guy I mean you
clearly have talent and ability and all
of that and a work ethic but it's not
like oh you were you're an NC to a track
you know track and field superstar know
coming into this no not at all you know
I've never ran a Boston qualifying run
yeah did you play sports when you were
kid yeah i played team sports going on
you know i played football in high
school I was I was a good football
player I wasn't great I didn't cut in
play
College or anything and then after that
I was I was not an athlete for a while
I rode bikes fixed gear bikes around
Austin just not like a young little thug
and it's been a lot of time in the bars
yeah it was much more in favor of that
lifestyle and wasn't taking care of
myself or my body and you know when I
moved to Alaska I think I was up to
about 230 pounds
no I meant 170 now and I fluctuated a
lot no I've not always been in touch
with my body on like an athletic level
and only in the last two years have I to
a high performing level mm-hmm
it's a great place to be now though and
I do know that you know I've just the
tip of the iceberg like I want to
continue to push and I have like a sense
of I feel legit now
you feel right there what what else did
you learn about yourself like this is a
journey of self-discovery it's mental
and emotional and spiritual I would
argue even more than it was a physical
feeds like you had to confront yourself
in profound ways like what did you learn
mm-hmm
on the surface level devices our phones
are distracting us from a lot of things
that really matter being forced to not
be around my phone for so long was so
amazing and allowed me to ponder life
and also be open to people when I did
come in contact with them it was a
really big thing you know I think we put
up a lot of walls and we have a lot of
labels for different types of people and
different people in regions of the
country and stuff and we get all of that
those these assumptions about each other
based on updates on our phone and having
to put that down and interact with
others I found that people were
extremely beautiful and awe-inspiring
and just interesting just the random
like guy in overalls and Missouri just
blow your mind with the stuff that they
had to say that was a big thing yeah I
mean just to extrapolate on that a
little bit sorry to interrupt if you're
on Twitter
it's very easy to fall into a state of
despair thinking that were at each
other's throats and that we live in you
know in a country that's very much
divided ideologically politically and
there's a lot of like vitriol and and
downright hatred out there and there is
but there's something about the tactile
experience of boots on the ground at
that slow of a pace that gives you a
very different lens like I have a friend
who every year takes train he's not you
know he's not an ultra distance runner
on our beat he takes a train
cross-country every year and he gets off
at every stop and spends time and
connects with people in a real way and
and you know he will say and I'm sure
you will echo this you know what I see
what my real life experience of going to
all these places is very different than
what you would imagine based upon the
narrative that's being propagated by
social media and and even you know news
and newspapers and the like yeah I
couldn't agree more we're giving up a
lot of our power and a lot of our
ability to connect to these devices and
these few powers that be that run them
or it's not even that I don't think that
there's some like body orchestrating it
from behind I think it's just what's
happened it's just the way we're
receiving information it's through a
filter that's not reality and there's
just a lot more beauty out there and we
have a lot more in common than we have
we have these key issues that are stupid
and while they're not something they're
not stupid but there's there's a lot
more to human and to individuals and
what were what we're getting through
these updates and through what we see I
mean social media that one was very big
that was profound for me I definitely
put a lot of those walls up for myself
and then the other one and also sorry
doing it again but going back to truly
the original catalyst for this whole
thing was an ideological difference with
your aunt yeah yeah exactly and you know
that was a struggle as a struggle I went
through and a lot of people went through
was this just the Mint's love for
someone or multiple people in your life
that you see something so so polar
opposite from and it helps to come back
and heal those things or have a better
understanding of that those small
differences don't equate to enough to
feel separate from those that you love
that might see things differently or
even a random person on the street how
are you and your aunt now I'll work
great oh you are that's good we have
always been she was someone that I mean
I love her to no end and you know she's
been there for me and is still there for
me at times and right now in such a
profound way and that's what made it so
that's what makes it so painful and we
get into these like political debates
like it's just it's such a minor part of
who we are as individuals as those
things so yeah that was there was a lot
of self-discovery in that for sure yeah
also I would imagine having you know
accomplished this that you must have an
expanded sense of your own personal
capabilities you know outside of just
running like if I can tackle this and
achieve this like what else am i capable
of like where else can I apply whatever
skillset I developed as a result of this
endeavor to other areas yeah for sure
you know once you chase your dreams and
you get on you know maybe it makes a
little easier to go for them the next
time we're like you have to because you
know it's possible
well that but that it's a two-edged
sword though right because you know
there's an existential crisis o achieve
something like that like okay do I have
to top this and what am I gonna do now
there's a vacuum mm-hmm for sure
I don't know that you can top this as
far as I can internet feet but I
definitely want to deployed your man
card you don't have but I mean I do want
to do more you know I want to keep
pushing myself physically in an
endurance endeavors
you know conversation I had recently
kind of resonate it resonated with me
with dot C Our Mutual Friend Ozzie Bosch
and we were talking about plant
powered athletes and you know there's
still not enough of examples of us and
why we're all just individuals so it
kind of made me want to Double Down
like well I can't be more than just me
but I can continue to do things and then
of course that's like the most virtuous
reason I would want to do this but also
you know it's fun it's like what I love
I want to continue to push the envelope
but also outside of it on a more you
know interpersonal level and in other
parts of life you're right
I definitely mentioned earlier you can
have anxiety in battle anxiety and I
find now that it's way more manageable
because I feel as though everything is
overcome Abul I have that that that
strengthened myself and an understanding
that I can get through it
most things are Oklahoma bull and you
can get through it there's been since I
finished there it is it's open-ended
whoo am i what am i doing next I worked
on this like what is my mechanism to
move forward in so many different ways
as an athlete as a person financially
all of these things and they could bury
me how can be buried by these things and
anxieties but instead I'm keeping my
head above water you know there was a
there was a really dark month I'd say
right right about the time I saw you and
yeah no I got that sense like you're
like okay like the the excitement of the
whole like being in New York is exciting
but you had just gotten back from that
and that was just on the heels of
completing it so I think the reality was
just beginning to set in oh yeah
yeah and it was you know going back to
profound things I learned you you
touched on this recently with Zach Busch
I think it was there some some form of
this but what one thing I realized out
there in retrospect and once it was over
when it finished I felt a big sense of
loss of a lot of things that I wanted
around me weren't and the realization
that there's a couple things that make
me feel full and one is direction the
others community and feeling heard
mm-hmm and when I was on this run
I had clear direction of those Northey
yet all the time I had a crew around me
that was there to support me and they
were community and I was always heard
whatever I said they wanted to hear and
they wanted to you know understand and
reacting accordingly and taking that now
I just want to make sure to keep those
things present in my life like it
doesn't have to be a goal of running
across
tree but I think everyone should always
have some type of a goal whether it's to
just retain so that you can have a
better more fulfilled day or run a
marathon or whatever it is you should
have a goal well there's something about
being deeply engaged with an activity
that you love and also a group of human
beings as well oh yeah yes you're being
heard but you're also part of this clan
like you know I would imagine for the
rest of your life there's gonna be like
an intimacy with those people because of
what you guys collectively into word but
if you were proceeding on the belief
that like this is gonna fix me or like
you know when I'm done with this then
I'm gonna be good you know that's the
deal that's that's the really alluring
delusion and the whole thing right
because then you finish it and you're
like you're still you you did this
amazing thing you were you you were in
your peak state and all of that but
fundamentally life goes on yeah and
that's that was something that was real
you know that was something I think I
was feeling there was a moment when I
are somewhere in this when I was setting
out on it is that it would it would it
would I would just get done and birds it
be turkey sandwich doors are gonna swing
open and like the rest of your life is
gonna get taken care of
yeah and and that's not the case and
then you really look at it and you
wouldn't want that to be the case
anyways right you know it's all about
the journey and and just looking to you
know what can what can I do next and I'm
not talking about upping myself or
making you know it's just to keep moving
forward forward momentum is important in
life and keeping people around you you
love and people that used to support you
and you want to support and trusting in
that trusting in those relationships so
that was a really big part of it for me
for sure what was it like when you
finally got into Central Park and
completed the whole thing it was a major
sense of relief initially you know just
like I get to wake up tomorrow and I
don't have to run uh-huh instead I woke
up and Shelly made me we would got a cup
of coffee and then we were straight to
the barber that was the first act of
business just to clean up a little bit
so that was the that was the move of the
day but yeah sense of relief and a
overwhelming sense of accomplishment and
pride
I definitely shower Oh real shower yeah
a bed that wasn't in the back of a van
in New York City was a wild place to be
coming out of this there was a lot to
grapple with well I was out there had
the ability to everybody I talked to
outside of my crew was hitting me while
I was running right when I got done
running
so left-brain right-brain are just like
they're connecting they're driving
really well and you get done and you're
not doing that anymore and all of a
sudden
conversations were really hard I feel
like I couldn't keep up with
conversation submitted some social
anxiety I had a hard time navigating
really simple technology like the metro
putting money on a metro card not easy
for me haha it's the most simple like
interface may and you had to go and like
speak at that there was the plant-based
nutrition yet conference right yeah was
going on at the same yeah and that's why
I stayed around New York was that was
ten days after I finished and the plan
was just a lot of downtime and just take
it easy do that event zip on home but I
ended up having lunch with our mutual
friend John Joseph uh-huh and he just
opened the doors of New York ya know a
sudden there was engagement you gotta
call me before you know I got a guy for
that exactly why are you eating there
organic grill floods gonna hook you up
and he did and Vlad was amazing you know
that and yeah the Recovery Center and
just all these different engagements but
it goes back to like one of the things I
learned from this was perseverance and
although I had all this social anxiety
and I didn't feel up to these social
engagements I knew the only way through
it was to do it mmm and I every day woke
up and I put on a face and I went and I
engaged with people I had a massive
amount of impostor syndrome so hilarious
because you're you just ran across the
United States yeah but I think it's like
but I ran across the United States I had
normalized it I had to to do it and so
all the sudden you know I I'm at
the at the the Recovery Center and I get
out of this infrared sauna and there
were a couple people that waited to say
hey to me they wanted to meet me and
that's never happened in my life I was
like well but why and it's taken a lot
of time to start understanding that and
to give gravity to what I did so that I
can two degree process it on the same
level everyone else does so that I can
you know move forward and know what I
have in front of me and this
accomplishment that I've had what it
means to me and what it can what it
means to others so that I can use it to
to my advantage in to the advantage of
the advocacy yeah and you had you I mean
my advice to you would be to own it like
it's charming that you have a healthy
sense of humility around the whole thing
and I think that's great
but at some point you have to say okay
well this is what I set out to do
there's a reason that I accomplished it
and this can be leveraged for good and
in order to really do that you have to
step into the power of it right and just
and and and own it and it doesn't make
you like a crazy egomaniac to do that if
you do it in a healthy way and you see
people do this in different ways like a
lot of people do it with alter egos like
I had the guy who wrote the alter ego
book on here and you see what James
Lawrence does he creates the iron cowboy
because it doesn't feel right to James
as James to be that superhero guy for
whatever reason but he knows when he's
yes I'm the iron cowboy he can talk
about these things in a different way
yeah yeah and that's something I'm
definitely still grappling with and
figuring out you know on the way here I
was a little nervous about this podcast
and I definitely like said to myself in
like the mirror of the car I thought you
ran across the country I mean nervous
talking to you you know no it is it is
it is amazing and and I think I think
it's important that you not rush this
next phase that you're in and allow
yourself that time and that space to
really figure it figure out like what
you want it to mean for yourself and
what you want your
to look like like you're gonna have
opportunities but because perhaps you
feel that vacuum there there might be
like a sense that you got to rush in and
do something because an opportunity my
pass or whatever and I think it's okay
to like not quite know right now yeah
yeah and I am I'm settling into that and
you know I think initially when I heard
things like that and actually from you
at dinner in Denver it made me feel is
like okay well I'm not supposed to move
my body I'm not supposed to exercise
like in in that I know is like it's in
I'm incapable of that it's what I it's
one of those things that I really need
and want but as far as a larger larger
goal yeah I'm kind of resting in right
now of just enjoying the moment enjoying
the space I'm in and and you know I like
reaping the benefits of what I've done
and and feeling accomplished for a while
instead of yeah striving for that next
day but I'm already finding new passions
in ways I'll never never quit running
running his primal its what it's the
most perfect exercise but I'm enjoying
I'm getting on the bike now that's me
I'm really enjoying that a good friend
of mine in Austin he's a Red Bull
cyclist really big and gravel road
racing Colin Strickland and he described
like cycling to me and a really I don't
know profound way the other day and it
was that he's so taken back by what I
did and his thing is he's like look when
you run your the motor and the
drivetrain and you look at a car what
goes out first the drivetrain he's I get
on a bike and you just get to be the
motor and with all the pains and the
stuff I felt my legs and trying to
recover that really resonated that you
know getting on a bike is such a like
lower impact way to move and you move
fast it's amazing how many miles you can
you can just like it's in no time you
don't already cross country a lot fast
so I'm enjoying that I think that's
something I want to I want to pursue to
some degree it's getting on the bike I
like the long distance stuff the gravel
road stuff really seems interesting 200
mile races yeah it's wild the Kwanza
yeah
Kansas yeah that's cool yeah I think
it's good and I think
yeah if you can distract yourself with
another audacious goal and and I think
there are other audacious goals that are
appropriate for you to chase and do that
but I I my only thing was just like you
know allow yourself to it's okay to be
also yeah you know yeah just be and I
think that is important you know we can
we can use these athletic endeavors in a
way to hide yeah and I don't that's dead
I I worked too hard for self-discovery
to go hide yeah doing another one and
you see that you know I think there are
a lot of people that do then and and
it's effective because everybody praises
you for it but actually it's a big mask
for some trauma or you know
psychological thing that you just are
too afraid to look at when you need the
quiet space and time to let with those
things you do to sink in and absorbed
with them and like absorb the lessons
you know I'm only - a little over two
months out from doing this and there's
still so much more I think that's that's
yet to come out and for me to understand
and if I if I was pushing really hard
already for something else I might not
make it to those things yeah so I think
that's right I think it's good to hold
back a little bit are you dude are you
doing a little bit of speaking I have
some schools and places like that asked
you to come and share your message you
know a little bit there was a lot in New
York and then getting back to Denver
has you know there's just I don't have a
lot of community there I don't think
anyone in Denver knows what I did yeah
and it is such a wild Kentucky Enver I
know you're listening reach out to Ravi
yeah he needs people to hang out with
and then I was just in Austin prior to
coming up here and you know I did a
podcast there mm-hmm
and hung out with the rogue running
people go in there great and that
community has embraced me a lot spending
time there's a new group forming there
that's a running group based around the
restaurant industry that a friend of
mine starting school the Commodore
rowing club and I really like me and the
chef from the restaurant Philip Speer
had talked about this before my run is
something that we were both really
interested in pursuing he's recovered
addict and he just wants to help those
that are going through that in the
industry and helped to get to some
before they have to get
has to get that pad yeah and it's you
can feel the energy
it just started about a month ago but
people are showing up more and more
people every day and I want to be back
and be there as much as I can to run
with them and help in that pursuit and
also virtually be with them just helping
with social media and stuff right stuff
like that yeah I want in
I'm I don't want to engage with as many
people about what I did is possible and
put my my hands and other things that
are important like that run club right
were you filming a doc on the run there
was some filming done we got there
before I started we put together a
couple minute teaser that it's already
out there about my intentions and
there's another piece in the work it's
nothing long but it's just gonna be a
little a little arrived view of my
experience yeah yeah yeah
and are you still doing stuff with
switch for good with Dulcy I mean dots
you're always talking she's kind of
turned into a mentor slash if you got
dots you on your side you just feel like
you can do anything she's so powerful I
mean just a force so we chat a lot and I
I would like to get more involved with
her outreach in the months to come still
just kind of getting back to
understanding what's what I want to
continue to work with not a move and
continue to perpetuate our plant we
coined this the plant powered mission
and I want to continue to do things that
will perpetuate that message and they're
a great partner and we'll just see where
it goes
right I want to help other athletes do
things too well let's let's land this
plane with final thoughts on what it is
that that you want people to take away
from this experience in terms of how
they can better empower themselves don't
get overwhelmed by the larger tasks and
goals at hand and chop things up into
little pieces and eventually if you do
that small things become big things I
think that and as we talked about
earlier kind of the arc of starting
something new or giving something up
understanding that
whatever it is it may it's gonna get
easier over time and it won't ever mean
if it won't require maintenance and
diligence but stick with it stick with
whatever it is there were many days I
could have stopped and given up because
it sucked but I chose not to and now I
get to forever have this this massive
thing that I did and yeah get to get to
celebrate and everybody has that ability
and whatever to whatever degree that you
want stick to it it stick-to-itiveness
but also holding loosely allowing that
universal energy to flow through you
breaking things down into little chunks
dreaming big you know a lot of it boils
down to these stupid adages that are so
true though like I just saw a platitude
the other day you know if you started
today imagine what it would look like in
a year you know it's like this things
are like annoying you know but they're
so true right it's like you know now
look what you get to do you get to go
around and share this experience that
you've had for the benefit of other
people and it's it's a gift man so great
to talk to you thanks for having super
inspiring what you've accomplished and I
can't wait to see what you're gonna do
next
keep spreading the message maybe
consider writing a book get out there
and talk and Denver Colorado right yeah
if people want to connect with you
what's the best place for them to do
that after Graham I'm pretty active on
ECM yeah it's my name Robbie Ballinger
v-a-l-e nger
Robbie Robbie bie and then also we have
a website plant powered mission comm
that I'm gonna get active on blogging
again soon cool and go get your not Amit
right yeah exactly you got to plug it
not the move
cool man we'll come back and talk to me
sometime again man awesome all right
peace
[Music]